ja hast du ein Herz gemacht aber hast in
Mitte
durchgeschnitten korrekt hallo ihr
Lieben verliebten
zuckermäuse wir machen heute was zum
Valentinstag und zwar last minute das
hier nicht wundern ich habe schon in der
Hälfte durchgeschnitten ist in 10
Minuten gezaubert und komplett nobig
absolut Anfänger geeignet also unbedingt
dran bleiben und Nachmachen so wir
starten jetzt mit unserer rosa cake poop
Glasur das ist ja immer ein bisschen
schwierig weiße Schokolade rosa zu
färben daher finde ich immer die
cakeepop kusur perfekt entweder in ein
Wasserbad stellen oder kurz in die
Mikrowelle ganz wie ihr möchtet und
jetzt nehme ich mir hier einmal diese
wunderschöne Silikonform ich finde die
Farbe auch richtig hübsch werde ich euch
in die Infobox verlinken ist ein ganz
ganz neues Produkt von uns und wir haben
das ganze auch noch mal in mini falls
ihr dort rezeptinspiration sehen möchtet
werde ich euch ja auch etwas
[Musik]
einblenden
so und jetzt wird die rosa cake poop
Glasur einmal hier drin verteilt und
dann versucht ihr das einfach mit einem
Löffel oder mit einem Messer so ein
bisschen auch an die Ränder zu streichen
danach geben wir das kurz für 5 Minuten
in den Kühlschrank oder ins Gefrierfach
und dann könnt ihr wenn ihr möchtet noch
eine zweite Wand machen falls sie zu
dünn ist oder ihr habt direkt schon
quasi eine dicke schokowand dann passt
das
[Musik]
auch
passt
[Musik]
ne
ham bisschen leiser ich mach schon ich
sag ihm das auch noch mal ja ja bisschen
leiser so jetzt haben seine Überraschung
der weiß nicht von seinem Glück so ich
nehme jetzt hier für die Füllung Kuchen
bitte wundert euch nicht was ich hier
für ein Kuchen habe ich habe ein Rezept
für euch experimentiert und ihr wisst ja
dass meine Rezepte immer gelingsicher
sind das hier war ein Fail und daher
sind so rezeptentwicklungen so
übertrieben wichtig und was mir danach
super gelungen ist ist der zweite Boden
und das wurde die leckerste Schokotorte
der Welt oh wenn ich dran denke ich
raste schon wieder aus und das hier ist
mein fail Kuchenboden deswegen nehme ich
den jetzt aber ihr könnt jeden anderen
Boden nehmen ich verlinke euch auch
gerne passende Rezepte für einfache
Böden oder ihr nimmt einfach ein
Fertigboden so und das wird jetzt unsere
Füllung das wird nämlich so eine Art
cakeepop Glasur und weil ich gerne in
die Mitte noch so wie so eine Art
flüssigen Kern machen möchte werde ich
jetzt hier keine cream oder so oder
nichts noch mal süßes benutzen sondern
nehmen ganz einfach Frischkäse und das
werde ich jetzt ein mit den Händen so
ein bisschen zerbröseln und vermengen
dass es eine cakepopmasse wird und dann
zeige ich euch wie wir
[Musik]
weitermchen cakepopmasse ist soweit
fertig ihr merkt das daran dass wenn ihr
es quasi zusammendrückt das einfach so
richtig schön fest ist und das Schöne an
dieser Herzform ist dass sie sehr
dankbar ist also man kann wirklich total
wild herumstreichen das Endergebnis ist
einfach immer hübsch solltet ihr euch
dafür entscheiden da jetzt einfach
Schokolade oder Kuvertüre reinzumachen
dann temperiert Sie am besten dazu zeige
ich euch ja auch mal meinen Videos wie
das geht also erst zwei Drittel
schmelzen überim Wasserbad und dann das
letzte Drittel schmelzen damit ihr kein
Grauschleier habt weil der cake
poopglasur habt ihr auf keinen Fall ein
Grauschleier da könnt ihr ja wie gesagt
ganz einfach mit umgehen und ich gebe
jetzt die cakeepop Masse hier einmal an
den Boden und an den Rand und lass aber
in der Mitte so ein bisschen was frei da
suche ich mir dann irgendeine cream von
uns aus da könnt natürlich auch nehmen
was ihr möchtet irgendein
überraschungskern also der hamser steht
voll auf milkjoy zurzeit schmeckt ja wie
das Innere von Kinderriegel das werde
ich da glaube ich reingeben dann habe
ich auch farblich noch mal so schön weiß
dann kommt restliche cakeepopm so oben
drüber dann wird das glatt gemacht und
dann einfach nur noch cake poop Glasur
boah für jedes Wort cake poop ein Schot
h D ich jetzt gesagt aber ein in
[Musik]
shot
so ich habe es jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
ins Gefrierfach getan das ganze hat
keine 10 12 Minuten gedauert also ich
würde schon sagen in 10 Minuten hat man
sein
Valentinstagsgeschenk fertig so und
jetzt einfach umdrehen dann vorsichtig
die Silikonform entfernen und wenn dann
noch Überschuss ist das wird bestimmt
passieren könnt ihr das einfach mit
einem scharfen Messer
[Musik]
abnehmen
egal ich habe die restliche cakeepop
Glasur einfach noch in mein Spritzbeutel
gefüllt vorne die Spitze abgeschnitten
und dann so gezaubert und anschließend
noch so Kristallzucker oder
glitzerzucker da drüber gegeben ich find
es richtig hübsch und dafür dass es so
eine Last Minute Idee ist in 10 Minuten
fertig ist finde ich es auch wirklich
sehr sehr hübsch also ham so wie ich
einschätze B denken ich s da bestimmt
ein Stündchen dran was glaubst du wie
lange ich dafür gebraucht habe ich weiß
wie lange dafür gebraucht hast sag mal
Stunde warum ja eine Stunde habe ich
dafür gebrauchtchst du so weil du
richtig geraten hast mich gewundert
sieht aber sieht aufwendig aus aber wie
findest du das
Herzem hübsch aus das sieht heftig aus
echt hübsch hier gemacht hatte willst
jetzt Überraschung sehen ich frage mich
gerade wie du das auch gemacht hast aber
egal erzähl okay bereit für ih drin
ja was das für eine weiße Füllung mil oh
mein Gott so und jetzt würde ich mal
sagen mich in dich verliebt also mich
auch aber auch ich würde sagen lass uns
einfach so das ist etwas das kann man
auch per Hand essen brauchar keine ja
Schneid dein Finger ist okay kein
Problem so
HS guck wie du das machst ne wieso ist
doch cool boah sieht richtig geil aus
ich bin so ein handesser ich mager kein
g Messer ohne Spaß ne also jetzt
natürlich W Nudel ist natürlich aber
sowas mag ich mit handessen so Tast
Test mssen angucken dabei
[Musik]
verliebte
ach boah lecker sehr lecker ich muss
sagen ich hab gegessen das war echt
lecker boah wenn ihr so ein richtig
saftigen Schokokuchen nehmt mit
Frischkäse boah richtig gut mega lecker
ich find es auch richtig gut Leute so
wie das aussieht so schmeckt auch mit
Liebe ja ich würde sagen beschenkt eure
liebsten beschenkt Euch selbst das muss
man auch nicht so Valentinstag kann
machen jederzeit auch zum Muttertag oder
sonst was bei uns ist jeden Tag
Valentinstag sowieso genau oder auch zum
Vatertag Vater bekommt auch Herz und
Liebe oder ja absolut kann muss nicht
rosa sein dann kannst auch
aber ja sehr schön und sehr lecker Leute
ja ich gönne mir das jetzt noch wir
gönnen uns das jetzt hier noch im Team
würde ich sagen ne und dann sagen wir
mal bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss ihr
Lieben tschüss die verlib
[Musik]
Mäuse